hello everyone
thank you for coming to this
presentation this is called generation
minecraft
kids building software this presentation
has two parts
uh there's the uh the fun part uh like
dessert
uh in a meal that comes at the end where
my crafty minors who are here i can do
some crafty mining
right they're much brighter at it than i
am um and so i'm very excited about that
uh and then like uh like uh so look at
this as a meal you have to have a
robust hearty main course where you know
this old person will talk to
other fellow wonderful people about the
state of creativity
why it's so important and i think some
of the things that we need to do
this is not a slide this is even more
zen than presentation zen
talks about in slides because there are
various problems but what this is
actually a website
i tweeted the link to this but it's gen
mc.heroku app.com
and so you'll be able to look at this
offline it should work just fine on
mobile devices
but it's really a pretty good takeaway
version of everything that we're going
to be talking about
here today right i've got a visual
outline
uh in a mind map if anyone's seen those
um
my whole spiel is pretty much here uh
when the video comes out i'll update the
page and we can watch the video
and then uh the kids the some of their
favorite minecrafters
uh we can find those links there
um so with no further delay i'm very
pleased to introduce my
biologically indentured subject matter
experts uh if i could please have my son
steve come up
[Applause]
uh and if i get also my daughter
herobrine
not their real name
okay so i'm very good so right so this
is the appetizer portion of the meal
where we're going to get up and talk and
do the introductions
um i just wanted to prove that yes
they're actually here and yes they
actually will be talking about minecraft
because i
um i do have a fair number of things to
say but while we're here i want to
start off with them present because this
is important for audience participation
knowing that putting the word minecraft
in the title of the presentation will
invariably bring people like minecraft
to it i still want to ask um
if you have ever played minecraft would
you please raise your hand
okay wow that's like everybody here nice
okay so the more specific and
interesting question uh if you know
anyone these guys age that plays
minecraft please raise your hand
okay that's like the same set of hands
that's that's really a lot
so that's really exciting because
minecraft
video games actually do more for
creativity than schools do for kids
and minecraft i think is one of the best
uh games that that helps with that
so you guys always raise your hands
right
no it's okay so we're all very nervous
so all right thanks guys very much i'm
going to call you up in a little bit
um after i'm done with the uh the the
boring stuff here all right
so thank you very much
[Applause]
very much appreciate that so um right
so my concern here is
it focuses a lot on creativity i'm going
to talk about a variety of different
things but
creativity is really really important
and there's a really good opportunity
with the internet
right the ones and zeroes that you use
to make botnets used to make
league of legends or hop scratch right
nominees have to be fracked out of the
ground
you know i don't have to you don't have
to have all this really expensive
machinery
to go you know to go get these natural
resources
right that's not the case uh with
computers or
that is the case with natural resources
in the natural world you need a lot of
equipment to uh to be able to access
these things
but ones and zeros are fundamental part
on the internet and how you arrange them
is
a creative effort i firmly believe that
programming is a creative effort
right there are many same ways to
achieve the same results some of them
are good
some of them are bad but there are
different ways and you pick the way that
you're
most comfortable a third that resonates
with you so that's one of my tenants
the programming is a creative approach
and i think everyone is creative
um so the creativity really comes to
bear much more on the internet because
the ones and zeros are there for
everybody and
it's it's a great opportunity for you to
be able to
make something so that's the that's
the opportunity is there
it's it's really good opportunity for
kids to be able to produce to create and
i'm not specifically just talking about
coding
in the hopscotch session which is
wonderful if you get a chance to watch
it please do
there was a lot of talking uh questions
about coding and if you look at games
like
there's a whole spectrum league of
legends for example right is there
anyone from riot games
here right now it's a question you can
only ask like a stranger
so very good so uh at league of legends
right i mean what percentage of the team
actually write code right i mean
not 99 of them not by any stretch it's a
huge complicated thing with with visual
design
and with music and uh you know
characters there's just so many
characters to pick from
so coding is not the only way that kids
can contribute
in the future right so it's important
that they be able to
so creativity is just a general purpose
tool
right and so that's going to be really
good in the future because
while when i was their age a compuserve
was the internet
all right anyone ever have a copyserve
account
all right that's okay right so you had
your your octal user accounts right
um and one fun little fact about
compuserv
uh they had 36 bit servers right their
words with 36 bits your
your bytes all had a parity bit so you
could detect half the problems but
anyway so so that was the internet in my
generation and boy it's just
come and gone so far and then i worked
for aol since they killed
a copy with a barrage of floppy disks
and
and cd-rom that's right and then that
kind of became the internet now the
internet is actually just the internet
or except for grandma um
and so uh so what will it be when they
get older right well we know that more
of the world will be online
they're going to be competing against a
bigger percentage of the world
right more people out there are going to
be ready to automate
stuff so if we if we focus on coding
that's the most important thing we can
do
that's really if you're a programmer
making a step in their future
step out of your past right it's the
same thing as the bat
the glove the ball that someone pushed
in your hand that you didn't like
it's the same approach so i'm going to
get into that
a little bit later but it's it's a
concern that that i do have
um right so in the future so this is the
the challenge
um if you don't develop your creativity
and
you choose to work on computers in the
future you're only going to be able to
do
other people's ideas and you're going to
be competing against a bigger portion
of the world so i think it's really
important that you are able to be
creative
because then you'll be able to start
your own ideas and
move forward on those um
right so i'm going to go ahead and pull
up my mind map here very briefly just to
give you an idea of
the sort of things that oh
right so this is the wi-fi ah right so
that
much is on the internet sorry so but
this is all these are all running
locally and you can access all the same
stuff plus you can actually see this uh
this big outline um right so
the the problem with creativity
depending on creativity as a
general-purpose tool is that
who is encouraging creativity schools
are
doing a terrible job right seymour
popper um
he wrote a book in 1980 mindstorms right
um
samantha recom i also recommend it as
something you can actually
uh as a really good next step if you're
concerned about any of this stuff
um right so he said
you know in 1980 someday computers will
be as affordable and cheap as
televisions
right and they'll be a tool that can
revolutionize education right we may not
even need schools
so it has come true that computers are
everywhere i mean we have computers here
we have
just just everywhere and the quantity of
time kids are spending on the computers
is increasing
the quality of time is really not
increasing um and so
one of you know the standardized tests
this is
something that they spend a lot of the
time on office skills and typing
okay none of these things encourage
creativity it's it's really
uh uh it's the creativity is almost the
opportunity cost
right that all this time they could be
spending just doing freeform exploration
and producing something anything kind of
honing your creative skills
they're not they're picking from a
pre-true list of choices
which is unrealistic because it's you
know there's no one in this room that's
ever
impressed anyone or got a promotion
because they picked you know the most
plausible answer correctly
so it also leaves a bad impression in
kid's mouth this is not
the way adults use computers right we
rely on google
we rely on stack exchange to to load and
store information
but what we're making the kids do is be
a little biological load and storing
devices we just like a foie gras right
which have a whole bunch of information
so they can regurgitate it
correctly and that's their experience
they have in a computer
that's terrible you don't want them to
look at a computer as
like you know a regurgitation area but
they know
that it's not really used that way in
the real world
the other problem uh is a bit of a
perverse incentive for teachers
right i'm here because i had a couple of
teachers really
make a difference in my life right they
took the time to help one kid that
needed something that they recognized
and they made a big difference
so with standardized tests the teachers
who are systematically rewarded
for making kids the same so if that's
where your focus is trying to make as
many kids as
the same as possible it's a disincentive
to actually help
any one kid be different to make a
difference when anyone could
and so my fear is that the
the next generation of teachers who's
going to apply to that if they know that
the people who are more successful
are people who crank out you know the
most cookie cutter kids
so that said if you do want to make a
difference to generation
please teach please it's a wonderful
thing don't give up
i'm confident that we will get all this
this mess sorted out
so right
so um
okay so at this point
i'm gonna go ahead and we're gonna go
ahead and ask some kids some questions
um if i complete a hero brian come on up
thank you sweetie and we're gonna go
ahead and launch minecraft like i said
this is definitely a
minecraft presentation so um let's see
can you come on over here
so first of all thank you for being here
and you don't have to be too close
that's probably about good enough
so tell me uh what is the server um
a server is like a playground but online
um people can play can't get off
and it's overall just fun really
and you can share ideas with each other
and
again like my dad said just create
everything
thank you so tell me about collecting
taxes um
well as you might know already i own a
server
it was given to me by my dad and
go ahead and so so the server so the
server is where is something that we
control
right and it's something i've set up
i've accessed all the chat logs so i
know who's talking to who when
uh it's a great mix of boys and girls uh
boys
mostly boys yes what there's only like
two other girls to get on
well okay but i know what they're
talking about um
which is really good so i want to look
at the world you guys have built
together because this is really
neat um and steve i might need your help
on the full screen
for what are we looking for looking for
oh your hero grind that's who you're
looking for where can i define this
thank you what's the full screen for
do you know f11
not that one here we can either drag it
or here can you release the mouse
yes okay there we go okay
so um this is a world that they have
worked uh hard to build
but it's it's a digital playground one
of the big benefits is that we moved
uh quite quite away from their friends
and they were able to use minecraft to
which had none of this
by the way this is just this was just a
flat world this was just nothing
um and they
they put it together i mean so what are
we looking at here
um a floating ship apparently and
one of my favorites my castle all right
it's filled with chickens by the way i
like chickens
and i named them is this one
yes what's that go back i missed it
niall waddles burt waddles yes you need
them
little eggers mario models very good
um and it's to really underscore that
the real world does come into play
um she happened to have an irresponsible
father who was doing a bad job of
backing up the server
um and what happened um
someone one of my friends from out of
town
um and he showed the server to his
friend
and he gave you know they're kind of
sharing the account
but then the friend
of my friend thought it would be funny
to grief me
killed my dogs and all my horses
and they replaced everything my house
was cake
i did not appreciate that so so you can
publicly shame me and slap my wrist
go ahead um um so right so this
is the real world i mean the kids bring
that the same things that they do in the
the playgrounds and such here i mean
they were just kids being kids
right this was this is just young kids
uh young kids
um okay now what do we have is that epic
the donkey yes
no it's a it's a mural it's a meal
what's the difference between a meal and
donkey
um mules are hybrids
good jobs so um right so this is one of
the worlds do we have
uh any of the other worlds that you
wanted to look at we have the monk swamp
world
oh my swamp right so this so this is
something that they've been able to
build on their own
um and so she would just say that's
herobrine
um and then also there's a fantastic
community one of the great things about
minecraft is um
it has a humongous community um
oh that's a good single player i'm not
opting on monster rifle
you're not opting on survival don't you
jump off the edge and show everyone what
that means
because i'll die um so this map was made
by someone else
and uh and it's just really amazing if
you haven't seen uh some of the things
that the people do
all right now you're making some
emotions
there's flat okay um
why don't we not this a single player
should have so anyways um oh hold on
have it
i have it ah cheating yes just like the
real world
um right so they don't have to
you don't have to start them off in a
flat world and expect that kids will
magically
build these amazing things right and my
i was kind of turned off
my first exposure to minecraft because i
just didn't feel like i was ready
to do these sort of things and it's just
it's really sort of intimidating when
you see all the things people can do
so there are good there's a lot of
community out there um there's a lot of
good maps there's a lot of people on
youtube um is there anybody
that uh specifically comes to mind that
you might like to mention
um i have cupcake i really like her
videos
i has cupcake these are on the uh the
website as well the things that we're
mentioning here
um right um earlier i said that um
minecraft does better or sorry video
games do better than schools do it
encouraging creativity
um that's most of them do not most of
them like uh
you're going to hone your collaborat
your competitive skills
uh you're doing one-on-one deathmatch
sort of stuff right so
competition is good the world is
competitive uh if you play league of
legends you know that's a collaboration
a
game that requires collaboration which
is also important in the real world
but none of those are actually
creativity or enhancer create creativity
but minecraft really does allow you to
do a competition and collaboration and
does reward creativity people
build stuff that they like and it's good
for them
i'm just doing commands don't mind me
don't mind you okay all right then
so very good
it's been something that uh i've been
really very um positive about one of the
things that we do at home
is we use what we call creative time so
kids can practice their creative skills
i think creativity is a skill like
anything else and i think in wax and
lane
based on your application of it uh and
it's easy to get a negative uh feeling
about it and to give up completely and
say
i'm not creative enough i'll never be
creative uh because somebody said
something i did sock door even where
somebody
uh didn't do any didn't respond to
something i did they just ignored me
it's sort of the worst of all worlds
right
but this is something where she's able
to use something
use a computer in a way that is not
not totally
trivial right this is not trivial this
we're working typing commands and we're
working on
a lot of different stuff so very good
so what are we doing here um i set
this account to a team and
on the team i can change colors of the
team name
so whoever's on the team will have their
name changed from white to the team
color name
so hold on all right so you can get
points and such
yes but i have no idea how to do that
you'll have to ask steve
speaking of steve i think we're going to
go ahead and bring him up here in just a
second
did you have anything you wanted to show
us right now no not really
okay very good so think about it and uh
if you think of anything come ahead and
uh
go ahead and run on up
very nice okay thank you very much and
we'll bring you back
all right mr steve if you would please
approach the podium
um so just as a brief introduction um
again steve's not his real name but uh
uh this is my son um i'm a huge closure
fan
and i actually help with one of the
closure meetups in dc area
uh where i'm pleased to say that this
wonderful guy writes a common lisp
and the reason for that aside from being
an ordinary teenager which is totally
awesome
um is that closure doesn't happen to
have any good kids programming books
whereas conrad barsky who's a wonderful
polymath has land of list but now realm
of racket
right and so these are actually good for
kids the closer books seem to be aimed
at
pissed off java developers and that's
not a really
a good experience for kids to get
started with so
yeah so it's something where we didn't
want to start them on programming
um because uh again i feel like uh
coding is not necessarily the right way
to make the good first impression to
help that
get them interested in in doing more and
learning more um
steve happens like redstone uh more than
uh herobrine
um and so what are we doing here this
servers
our programmers obviously recognize the
well not not necessarily well
sorry i haven't missed a day of school
because i'm sick in two years and the
second i get here i get it cold
um let's have some interesting stuff
this is a logic gate it's a not gate
so this lever represents the input and
we have the output is this lamp
so if the input is false or it's not
transmitting a signal
the output's going to be on and then
reverse
and then you have an and gate
so explain what the uh what do we see
here so this is we have torches right
are these a special kind are these that
torches um carry a charge of either one
or zero kind of like computer bits
and that when the block they're on is
being powered
for example by this lever then
it'll reverse the charges and it's by
default on
so here we've got just the output is on
only if both inputs are off but
and that just broke it okay then
and so what are you using here to do
this sort of applied electrical
engineering
um there's a material you can find in
survival it's fairly common called
redstone
which is kind of like a conductive wire
i guess
that will transmit a signal from a
source
like one of the torches or we have a
block
and you can do some pretty cool things
with it for example
this load so much faster than my
computer
for example this is a mini game that
someone created
using completely vanilla no exterior
alterations redstone
and it's fairly complicated this isn't
the complicated part
so these are circuits these are all
circuits
and the most interesting part of these
blocks command blocks
that you can input command line
things into and it'll execute it when
they receive a signal from redstone
and that's kind of like an if that when
it receives an
update if the condition in it is true
it'll output a signal
and you can get some pretty cool results
from that
as you can see this is a kind of tower
defense
sort of thing and i think i already
broke it when looking around so i can't
exactly show you but
so so you can so these circuits are
pretty low level right you can build
calculators in minecraft i didn't
transfer that world yeah there's the
same guy made a working calculator
for function once again completely
vanilla just using command blocks and
redstone so yeah it
gets pretty interesting and the thing
that's cool about this is it actually
people are like
hey if i do x y z then
it'll make this happen and all my
friends will be impressed and we can
have fun with it and i just crashed the
game
we're on the latest snapshot anyway yeah
there are a lot of crashes in this
but yeah and then
this is a pvp sort of team oriented
capture the flag map
that my friend and i have been working
on for the past month
or so and then you get the circuitry
this is an old version this is hardly
any of the
circuits but all of this stuff was
because
people wanted to have fun and they just
decided to make that happen
like what do you mean created all this
so basically the motivation behind this
was
we wanted to make a pvp map that we
could play on server
and have all our friends together and
have some fun with it
and we just decided to do this and
let's see if i've snapshot's broken it
yep so but the intent was you could have
classes and weapons with
enchantments yes there are different
classes and weapons and stuff
and then there's teams there are four
teams that are all trying to go against
each other to eliminate each other and
in the end be the last one standing and
capture all the other team's flags to
kind of capture the flag
so does this require any special
plug-ins on their part or on your part
um this did not this is completely
vanilla however some people
i can't show you because this is new
update and it's not compatible
but some people have gone beyond
redstone circuitry and they've actually
written java code
to create text interfaces and new
commands
and completely new game modes
in this game and it's completely you
don't have to do anything you can just
log on
and play so that's another motivation if
you like
stuff like that then like hey let's
write some java and make it happen or
something that interprets into java sure
sure um okay so real briefly
and get your air quotes ready tell me
about
the hunger games so
people have created a thousand server
network
that runs hunger games there's no
internet daily there's no internet
it runs hunger games resets repeatedly
and it's completely java operated
completely and completely
self-sufficient and there's
if you go on websites for minecraft
then you'll actually find even without
quotes you'll find
hunger games maps it's just
a genre now that people have completely
created out of this
because they wanted to be creative and
they have the cornucopia and this is
again the last person standing
totally community developed and they've
moved it's such a big thing where
they've actually moved the servers
closer to the data
i'm sorry the people people are not data
um but they it's so important that the
the network latency is good that they
have you know regional servers
right this is something you know i just
want to highlight the fact if you take
away anything from this your kids are
playing the hunger games of other you
know random people
uh if they have access to minecraft
multiplayer so
uh there is a lot out there um so
uh let me think so is there any
particular teacher you might like to
thankfully have a chance um
thinking about going back to
standardized tests topic yes
i had one teacher that really did make a
difference and
that's something that i activated on
accident
um okay then
so i had a teacher and i'm not sure i'm
pretty sure it's not a coincidence but
he was the teacher of the one
kind of like standard class he was a
science teacher and that is the one year
that science does not have to
study and cram for a standards of
learning test so you don't have to teach
people okay here's the standards and if
you don't
learn them well then you're going to
fail and retake the class
and i would go up to him after class and
say hey blah blah blah
special relativity and we'd get into
these like five minute long discussions
and i'd be late for my next class and
get yelled at
but point is people who teachers
the teachers that make a difference
aren't the ones that teach just to these
standardized
sort of guidelines the state set out
they're people that actually do try to
make a difference and
take entrance in their students
interests
and kind of their whole personalities
and this guy he was awesome he earns
money during power outages by generating
his own power and selling it back to the
power
power station the solar panels you've
got a solar
panel yeah all that sort of thing
so let's actually see
this is another kind of like a mini game
that someone created in vanilla
minecraft
without any java code editing it that's
like it's seriously a game three two or
three hours play time
you've got bosses you've got different
loot sets you've got mobs
it's kind of like cannon fodder enemies
and this is pretty impressive but it's
just created because people decided they
wanted to do stuff like this
and i think that's pretty pretty neat
yeah totally great um so
uh very good now we're going to
start taking questions here in just a
second one thing that i did want to say
is that as good as minecraft is and as
excellent as it is
it's not good enough right nothing is
good enough
not nothing but no thing right because
people are sort of the problem and
people are the solution
if we get thank you steve
[Applause]
um so you know you don't want to leave
the
schools leave it to schools to make your
kids help your kids become creative
because they'll get sol
standards of learning okay that's
exactly what i meant
so don't just leave it to the schools if
you leave to the friends they'll get
better at competition
and collaboration if they play games
that allow changes by anyone such as
minecraft then that will help their
creativity
um but it's again not enough you can't
just throw minecraft and hope that
they're gonna have like good creative
skills
uh what's worked for us at home is 30
minutes a day
five days a week they get creative time
right we say you have two or three
different types of options
i'm not allowed to show it here but
young steve has done some stick figure
animation that he turned into
more animations with like sounds and
there's
very amusing and that was something that
that was a nice to see it was
well-rounded it was an aspect of him
that he didn't know about
i i would never have because i'm not
talented like that i would never
suggested it
it was something that that creative time
allowed him to pull out
right something he just had access to
something and he played with it
and he liked it so we made it better got
him sticks which is a really nice uh
vector animation program and then he was
using what quicktime player
how how are you stitching the sounds in
imovie and something he just picked up
and was playing around with
they had the tools that he had at hand
um and i like them very much even though
i'm not allowed to show them to you
they're
definitely wonderful um and something so
we do the creative time so we do it with
both steven here o'brien uh if they're
unlucky during the summer they have to
use khan academy
they don't like it i think it's a
wonderful thing they it's a really good
approach to doing standardized tests
because so you know it's good right um
because it's not just abs if you get a
wrong answer there's streaks and there's
there's all sorts of monitoring you can
do i i really do like that helps keep
their skills sharp over the summer
so anyways don't just leave it to
schools don't just leave to the friends
if you are in a position to influence a
young child
just give them just like musical
instrument it's just like anything
give them time help them focus give them
a few options and just iterate on it
because creativity is a skill and
everyone has it you just have to help it
grow it's just sort of intangible it's
an investment but it'll be there when
you need it
that's my take so um if i can get steve
and herobrine back up here
we're gonna take uh questions um
this is uh it could be uh pretty much
anything
um i'll come up and
yes so uh do i have any questions
gentlemen the brown shirt uh so i don't
want to be selfish but i do have two
questions
um one for you and one for your kids for
you
i have a preschool-aged kid
and i'm very analytical and you know
nerd
and what did you find was the best way
to relate to
your children at that age to kind of
progress into such a
uh articulate state as they are today
and for your kids i'm curious to know
what you guys appreciated most about
your parents responding to you
in growing up and just exploring things
okay so i'm going to restate the
questions you guys can go first um the
kids um how awesome are mom and dad
and helping uh maybe do you guys want to
repeat that you can restate the question
but that's number one
how do you you know what what what did
you guys like and dislike with the
approach we took
um i liked that
um they understood that sometimes
we really wanted to get on and
like we have like set times during the
day where we can play video games and
when we can't
you know sometimes when we're bored we
well i not really my brother
but i ask if i can you know get on
when i'm not allowed to and instead of
just saying immediately
no they actually think about it and the
answer is usually yes
to play creative stuff right maybe
yes maybe like minecraft maybe
yeah okay it's very good steve did you
have any thoughts um
not really much the same that there's a
set pretty much the same there's a set
amount of
video game time that you have per day
and then
generally you can have somewhat
unlimited educational time where you can
do stuff like
coding common lisp i did scratch
originally that was my kind of intro
into programming
minecraft um code academy i heard that
mentioned in the hopscotch presentation
that's pretty cool it's also accessible
from school which is nice
um yeah that's pretty much it okay
um great so the question uh was from a
parent's perspective if you're
analytical
um how do you help how do you help them
become excited
and go along these lines um you let them
pull you give them
choices because they don't know what
they want right but seymour popper says
it really won mindstorms kids
taught themselves to you know pick their
head up to look around to roll over to
to crawl to walk they teach themselves
so much starting from so little
so you want to give them the ability to
keep teaching themselves and not
force them down any one thing it's it's
a per kid thing
right you really want to support them
pay attention respond to what they like
i wish i had like an approach that would
generally work for everybody
um my best suggestion is you just you
just block aside time consistently
um the suggestion to play board games is
wonderful hopscotch i think is
fantastic because it's very narrowly
focused and it looks nice
uh scratch is available if you do
something cross-platform
and scratch is really nice because it's
so things that work together fit
together
what are you doing to the port are you
spawning ender dragons
no it's a wither right that's a weather
yes but i can't one
don't spawn into dragons
[Laughter]
so did that answer your question it's a
little roundabout
okay very good uh yes ma'am my
question's for the kids
um great great uh demos by the way we've
got some sales engineers at work
um but i'm wondering for the
the when you're building the different
components and you know you're using
different levers and different elements
to sort of pull these engineering
concepts together
how difficult did it seem when you were
kind of
first learning those things and kind of
what helped you grow in that to building
more complex
things so you want to restate that
question did you did you follow like
yes um well let's see
i didn't really have any strategies
except practicing over and over again
so so to say so the question was how do
you become familiar with the more
sophisticated things
um so the redstone is kind of the the
most complicated thing i mean that sort
of drives
most of the other stuff added raw json
inputs it's awesome
i forgot to show it raw jason's totally
awesome yeah
so this is the sort of thing so we
showed the logic gates and i thought
what if i tried to show him how to do
this
in you know something else like public
static void maybe not
right it's he wouldn't enjoy trying to
take that approach with that sort of a
tool but here he's doing
gates for fun so
there's not like as far as levers and
and some of these things that are that
are valuable in the mechanical world i
didn't see a lot of that in minecraft
the redstone she's not
uh it's not something that's interested
in her uh she's incentive running the
social network of her friends and making
them pay taxes and there's voting and
there's you know
this is something she's really latched
on to and so i really encourage that
um the young man when he picked up i
don't know i picked up president just
going crazy youtube
it's crazy the stuff that there's there
to build from uh it was their personal
interest
so did you have anything any special
people or things that
caught your attention um
i kind of just learned it because i saw
something watching minecraft youtube
videos i saw someone
doing a playthrough of a vanilla
redstone map
i was like hey that's pretty cool so i
wanted to try to make something
like it and it just kind of all came
from there
um i yeah pretty much the same thing
i saw a couple videos and my dad it kind
of introduced it to me
and then i don't know why but i kind of
got lots
latched into it from that first
afternoon of playing the crappy beta
version
okay very good um let me see how much
time
actually we're about it on time i'll
take two more questions one from each
side
phil have you looked into the mod that
does the internal graphics style
uh yeah so the question was have you
looked into oh uh have i looked into the
like a logo style like logo style turtle
graphics mod
um steve um
i've looked at it a bit um i'm
considering installing i generally
when i look at mods instead of looking
like hey that's awesome i should
download it
i generally look at it at how can i do
this without mods
like how can i do this stuff that people
have written job before with just
redstone and the command blocks and
stuff that's kind of one of my
motivations
okay i will definitely take a look at it
after reading through mindstorms i think
that the logo turtle
approach is really really good and i
wish that i had started with that with
them a long time ago
because it's very concrete it's very
tangible if you look at mindstorms you
can look at the beginning
you know you start drawing the squares
that's fine you try and draw the house
on the triangle roof and the roof is
like inside the box so
you realize these long lists of
instructions become unwieldy
right so you start building subroutines
and procedures just from building stick
figures
like it works that inorganically it's
absolutely fantastic so
i will definitely check that out okay i
have time for one more question from the
side
what plugins do you have on your servers
none
no no so you just examine chat log how
did you
just take a look at the application
do you recommend any specific mods no i
was uh i was just wondering where i'm so
um we're actually building some
server-side plug-ins to do that kind of
stuff
really so anything you want like is
there
there's actually a i just tweeted
there's a
there's a course that uh a 13 year old
kid is teaching on how to build server
plugins in scala
really nice
nice oh very good very good okay yes
actually my friend the one i was working
on the kind of capture the flag map on
he taught himself all sorts of
like basic level java and server in and
out to that sort of stuff
because he wanted to install plugins on
the server so
doing stuff like that is great great
wonderful well thank you
um and the very last thing i needed a
couple thanks um
uh thank you steven here brian as this
is not as easy as it looks and was
especially hard to get started so you
did a good job so thank you very much
um and um it's very important that they
thank
my beautiful wife their wonderful mother
for years of support so
guys go give her a hug and uh